dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir the tango
pattern is a beautiful interval and
tapestry of basic stroke patterns like
dots straight lines and simple curves if
we look at some of these works we see
that many of these are highly structured
and maybe we could automatically create
such beautiful structures with a
computer and now hold onto your papers
because this piece of work is about
generating tangled patterns with
grammars okay now stop right there how
on earth do grammars have anything to do
with computer graphics or tangled
patterns the idea of this sounds as
outlandish as it gets grammars are a set
of rules that tell us how to build up a
structure such as a sentence properly
from small elements like nouns
adjectives pronounce and so on math
nerds also study grammars extensively
and set up rules that enforce that every
mathematical expression satisfies a
number of desirable constraints it's not
a surprise that when mathematicians talk
about grammars they will use these
mathematical hieroglyphs like the ones
you see on the screen it is a beautiful
subfield of mathematics that I have
studied myself before and I'm still
hooked especially given the fact that
from grammars we can build not only
sentences but buildings for instance a
shape grammar for buildings can describe
rules like a wall can contain several
windows below a window goes a windowsill
one wall may have at most two doors
attached and so on my friend Martin L
chick is working on defining such shape
grammars for buildings and using these
grammars he can generate a huge amount
of different skyscrapers facades and all
kinds of cool buildings in this piece of
work we start out with an input shape
subdivide it into multiple other shapes
assign these smaller shapes into groups
and the final tangle is obtained by
choosing patterns and assigning them to
all of these groups this yields a very
expressive powerful tool that anyone can
use to create pure
full tangled patterns
and all this through the power of
grammars thanks for watching and for
your generous support and I'll see you
next time